oh my god I'm gonna this is a
complicated architecture schools are the
like Yale Bab basically 50/50 I mean
maybe a fewer women than men but now
many and that's been true in
architecture school since I began to
teach pretty much it was definitely not
true when I went to architecture school
which was a boys club for sure but women
come to that there's a critical points
in their career where they embark upon
motherhood an architecture is a totally
time consuming disproportionate to any
amount of money any architect is paid
business plus the global reach of
architecture today demanding
unbelievable amounts of travel national
and international travel has added to
the complication and so women find it
harder they get torn between their
desire to have family and be with their
family and pursue their profession and I
think that's really the reason that we
are in the long run women are not seeing
where they should be at the top of the
profession because certainly in terms of
their talents and their professional
skills there's no difference between men